hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica look at
that gorgeous view filled with death in
every direction and no hope for anyone
who's alone on an island
not even on an island underwater and
dying forever and ever and ever I'll
never see another Hyun for as long as I
live
even I'm in a box alone talking to a
camera hahahahaha
ok anyway so enough crazy we have what
we need to are actually we have the
blueprints to do the modification
station so I got to find out where the
hell that is
modification station ah there we go so I
need a wiring kit and a computer chip
which I'm pretty sure I had everything
that I needed to do that because the
wiring kit is just silver and I have
more silver in mmm every uh we're
Mozilla Verizon oh not good oh there we
go I was well certain to panic for a
second there that was not okay and
apparently I discovered if you ate too
much of one thing it'll be bad for you
which I don't understand that at all but
whatever this is some Nautica we play by
their rules not mine okay so I got the
wiring kit and then I need to be able to
make a computer chip which is just table
coral sample because that's easy enough
give me some Corral anybody want a
little bit of curl is that table core oh
I forget girl shell yeah I think it's
the big tube thingy isn't it ooh hey was
that a was that a blammo I could use a
blam oh yeah Cantona is common core I
need table coral is that those stairs
this a table Goro table Goro I real cup
okay got that got that I'm gonna get
some extras while we're at it cuz a can
Epidaurus fall what about you Hakka
baloney what else do I have
Oh salt million pounds of salt I forgot
about that
really didn't need to cut back in salt
actually in my daily life - we got a
popcorn machine again and I had a
popcorn machine about two years ago uh
and that was a mistake because I ate
nothing but popcorn for the rest of my
life and I for like three months rate
ain't nothing but popcorn and I have a
terrible habit because I bought this
thing called flavonol and if you've ever
had flab a call it's like the yellow
butter flavored salt that they have in
movie theaters sometimes and it's so bad
for you it's literally like one one
serving size on the box is like three
times your daily recommended amount of
salt and I just dumped that [ __ ] on my
popcorn three like three or four times I
eat a bag of popcorn a day just dump it
on there I feel like my blood is just
turning into maple syrup except not
sweet it's with salt like the equivalent
amount of if you just mix salt with
water way down and dilute it like that
sludge that's what's floating through my
blood right now
so anyway no no why I need table coral
to be able to make a computer chip but I
got that some now I will be able to make
a modification station put it right by
where the hell oh oh I thought I lost my
children you know I haven't seen him in
days but that's okay I'm not a negligent
dad there you boys are Jeffrey Billy Sam
wasn't mom Sam wasn't Marshall you
weren't there for a second had me
worried man that ship is wow that is
booking it across the guy book okay so
now that I have that I should be able to
make the modification station which I
don't know where this spoon to go is you
key I'll put it down here then I was
under the assumption that it would be up
by the mobile vehicle Bay but apparently
not what does it go inside what I'm
confused now hahaha uh-oh
inside I didn't know that how was I
supposed to know that it's there right
great great right ha I suppose that's as
good a place as any
wink okay soon why steal pain oh boy
okay so plasteel extra light tank and
extra air capacity
wirelessly charges your held tool while
you swim what that's so cool
what oh sweet dude oh that's so cool
okay so I got lithium I do have lithium
down to my dive into the underwater cave
there here it is so I have lithium so I
should be able to make the plasteel air
contain but I could also make high
capacity I don't know which would be
better because I don't know if weight is
even a pro would probably just make it
smaller and there uh that would be cool
Sena could have more of them but I don't
know if that means that so I'm just
gonna go with thee I'm gonna go with the
extra capacity one for now and then I'm
gonna make another one that's ultra
lightweight now I must see what the
difference is so maybe a bit a little
bit a little bit a little bit a bit of
butter
oh this so cool I can oh 105 that's
awesome mmm that's so cool I'll put all
the salt and Billy need to get rid of it
after my salt speech you guys understand
I have a problem okay so that's there a
beauty so I need silicone rubber that is
really cool if I get another wiring kit
I should be able to make another one of
those that is so cool oh that's so cool
because if I have that then I would
never need to replace a battery in my
doobie dabby that sounds way better I
need more table Coral oh god damn it
it's night again I hate this I hate so
much how do I make wise my why you're
doing I have a light oh right click okay
got it
oh god it's so scary maybe I just did
that on my on my uh my seemeth and I
didn't know it probably I once again I'd
like to go with the idea that I'm stupid
more than anything else so this is
continue on that path
probably drains a lot more energy than
not having that okay anyway so now we go
in here and I should be able to make
another wiring kit no that was just
silver oh I didn't uh know that and what
oh it was probably the whole thing okay
silver silver silver where could you be
oh no silver I have lost thee I only
have one goddamnit
ah I'll be right back and this one shall
be for Samwise but I did that wrong hang
on a second let me not get ahead of
myself have it a boop-boop put that over
there uh keep that with me put that over
there cuz I don't need to know where
that is just yet but this one is for
Samwise the unsung hero of pretty much
everything ever oh it's a day yet god
dingus damn it hmm I'll try the thermo
blade that time just freakin badass why
wouldn't I want that there's no frickin
cool
oh man I'm kylo Ren look at me ah it's
even bubbling water here in the air for
some reason I don't worry about it's
cool it's so cool ah
take this who wants to challenge me
Darth Vader is my idol
oh I'm a Wimpy baby except I'm not
really cuz I was I won't say [ __ ]
spoilers god damnit cool another
terraformer I don't know what the
terraformers gonna be able to do but it
sounds fun wink come here with your
sassy but haha i ha ha
yay silver if I hit him with this it's
guaranteed to be turned into silver by
the law of I say so if oh look by the
law of I say so done did work I'm a
genius
look it's gonna happen again Herbert Oh
gold even better except it's not what I
needed ball take it anyway because I'm
greedy even though I'm the only human
left ha boskie silver the law of I say
so does didn't work I'm a genius of
every capacity everyone shall bow down
before my amazing powers
kylo Ren kind of hard not to talk funny
when I got these hot coffee cups in my
mouth not sponsored by anything ever
except for something recently oh yeah
Bank see it works it always works if I
hit it with this it turns to boink
server my god that's a big pile of the
things that'll like I'm gonna go back
now because I got enough what I need yes
victory is right oh [ __ ] dear god damn
you son of a [ __ ] my seamoth no no oh
god damn it what the hell oh my god that
is the stupid freakin thing I earn I
can't be properly mad about it because I
got cough drops in my mouth and shoe
stupid my moment of victory this is
[ __ ]
no say a goddamn word this is such a
file of suck you all are laughing at
nothing nothing nothing at all
damn it okay I guess I deserved that one
thank Karen I just had a horrible
terrible thing happened to me let me
just make a wiring kit and get over with
it all right let's see what this does
the lightweight version uh what does
that mean what do you mean lightweight
didn't do anything it's the same size I
guess I could go I could stay under for
longer but they're the same new daddies
damn it I should organize he's better
why those of you who have OCD out at
home are not very happy with my
organization structure and frankly I'm
not either but does the best I can do at
the moment so just bear with me it's
it's it's not happy but you know it's
it's home so now my only thing I need to
do is recover my goddamn seamoth because
I goddamn blew it up because Geoffrey
Samwise and Marshall didn't build it to
regulation standards did you boys what
Dad no we did exactly as shut up
Geoffrey billion Samwise Marshall you're
okay you didn't stash me back paint Stan
shut up
Marshall okay let's see vehicles seamoth
blah blah blah and blah Frick maybe I
could make the Cyclops vast industrial
use submarine why would I want that this
is so stupid I'm gonna die want my
seamoth back I gotta make that all right
I think I have everything you need
titanium power so glass I probably have
everything any dumber huh but this is
cool though
I mean wait okay so if I'm if I'm
swimming with my Finny whinnies and I go
to this what did it do
is it why isn't it working
I'm wearing the fins wirelessly charge
my help to swim it's supposed to be -
why is it not doing that damn it you're
damn it are you kidding on that a
silicon god damn an amount of silicon
how is that even possible
god I'm getting sick of running out for
mundane crap when I got a whole building
full of building materials what kind of
life am i living why am i so southern
okay so I finally got what I need I'm
gonna finish up these materials and then
in the next episode I'm gonna happy I'm
gonna have my seamoth back because it
blew up by mysterious unknown reasons
not known to me and then everything will
be hunky-dory so bear with me until that
point and thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you
in the next video bigger pulsate another
Gabor's out